jackie thanks very much indeed so let's
go back to our breaking news this
morning on the new energy price cap
which will rise to 3 549 pounds from
october that's about an 80 rise i'm
joined now to get reaction by labour's
shadow chancellor rachel reeves so a
very good morning to you
what do you make of this new price cap
well although it was expected that
doesn't um reduce the severity and the
seriousness of this announcement it will
strike fear into the hearts of families
and pensioners
right across
the country and that's why labour have
called for the government to take autumn
and winter and to pay for that with an
extension of the windfall tax on the
massive profits that north sea oil and
gas companies are continuing to make
that is the right and the fair thing to
do is what labour would do if we were in
government now
well yes and you've laid out your plans
this freeze on energy bills over the
winter but a lot of people say it's an
incredibly expensive and only short-term
fix
it's a package of measures worth 29
billion pounds and that includes the
price freeze that would mean that no one
would pay a penny more for their gas and
electricity
this autumn and winter and it would also
mean for the four million customers who
are on prepayment meters who at the
moment pay more for their gas and
electricity than if you pay by direct
debit that they would no longer face
that premium which would help some of
the poorest people we would pay for this
through a package of um of revenue
raisers including eight billion pounds
from an extension of the windfall tax
14 billion pounds from repurposing
government announcements already uh on
gas and electricity and seven billion
pounds through the lower interest that
would be paid on government debt because
these measures directly reduce the
headline rate of inflation at which
much government debt
is dependent on
well yes you say 29 billion pounds but
is this fully funded i noticed that the
charity full fact today is raising some
questions about whether your plan
actually would cover this price cap rise
they say that your plan doesn't take
into account
most customers higher gas and
electricity consumption during the
winter it's going to be more expensive
and it falls short at the moment doesn't
it
well last time full fact fact-checked uh
some labor analysis they had to um
withdraw it a couple of days later
because they'd got their numbers wrong i
i worked as an economist at the bank of
england for many years before i became a
member of parliament i'm confident about
my numbers i'm confident that they stack
up but most of all i am very confident
that the package of measures that we've
announced will make a real difference to
families and pensioners who are worried
sick about what is going to happen to
them this winter
it would also benefit a lot of people
that don't need the help why are you not
going for more targeted help for those
who need it most
well we know that people on lower
incomes spend three times as much on gas
and electricity as a share of their
income than the richest households so
this will have a disproportionate
positive impact on some of the poorest
families we also know that the four
million people who use prepayment meters
are some of the poorest families and
pensioners in our country and our
package offers an extra
300
pounds
to them over the winter months so we
think it helps those on the lowest
incomes the most but also i would say
this i've been speaking to leeds money
buddies a charity that's very active in
my constituency helping people
with financial difficulties that they
say that there are people coming to them
now who have never had financial
difficulties before but are now being
thrown into chaos and disarray
by these energy price increases the
university of york say that two-thirds
of the households now risk falling into
fuel poverty and so it is important that
a package of measures helps people
beyond those who are on benefits because
the fact is that these devastating
increases in prices are going to have
impacts on people right through the
income distribution our package is
simple it doesn't rely on rebates it
just says the prices won't go up beyond
where they are already and that will be
funded in part by that big increase in
the windfall tax to ensure that those
people who are making big profits based
on these higher apologies rachel we're
about to fall off air i must thank you
and say thanks